council is that right rather than you
don't want to reconvene a ppp god no no
i've done that twice already thank you
very much
okay
yeah yeah
this is really exciting stuff there and
you'd be welcome to reconvene if you
wanted to and you'll have a great time
i'm waiting to hear what this new letter
sounds like yeah yeah
um and look welcome ross i'm not quite
certain we quite had our times right for
you but it's we're just it's great
you're back with us as well ross
so i appreciate that um
and look we we have a wee bit of work uh
to go through um this is obviously in
public which is fair
um should be for the sort of uh piece of
work
um but at the
uh
towards the end when i think we're in
the position that we'll want to pass
some resolutions
i will ask management to leave the
meeting so we have some time as elected
members and independents with
derrick our auditor actually is is chris
also on the line as well the the auditor
of the subsidiaries
um to yourself to uh chris is
with um derrick at the moment doing the
final checks but i'm not i haven't had
confirmation he'll be logged on okay
right here uh chris sorry i don't think
i know what chris's last name is sorry
but uh sorry
yeah chris is the auditor of the
subsidiaries
um but but works closely with derek over
the whole group order so whether he's
with us or not but with the derricks
with us we're still working literally on
the opinion
but um as we wait just just a couple of
things um
passed around are what patricia you need
to just give us a rough heads up so that
we know what we're looking at
so in front of you you'll have the
what we understand will be the draft
audit opinion from audit new zealand and
the letter of representation which
the council needs to provide audit which
provides
certain comments about
that the
processes have been done correctly
it also has lists at the very last page
two uncorrected misstatements
um that we've agreed that we won't
correct they are not material um there
would have been another one there
however it was material and that is the
reason for the delay this afternoon yeah
thank you
so as we um when we formally start the
meeting we go live stream obviously
we're back to
where i had to avoid which was that we
moved to accept these major late items
which are three the annual report itself
um the opinion the draft opinion or the
opinion because i think it's going to be
more than draft be in the next few
moments and also the letter of rep um
we'll hear michael from you and patricia
i'll leave it to you guys as to whether
your tag team will not i'll invite derek
to make comments in public
uh
open discussion for council and then i
will um ask derek to speak directly to
the election members that all being the
case it looks like we've got an auditor
on board which uh is
must be a sign that we're good to go
just give us a couple minutes focus to
see derek on board and just check we are
good to go it's okay
[Applause]
welcome uh
derek how are
hi bruce uh
for yourself
good we're grateful to see you it's been
a long day but it's probably been even
longer for you i suspect so uh
that's that's great and it's good to
have you here derek i was just um
talking about process as we move into
reconvening our meeting
for
what it's worth we are in public
it will be in public for the course of
the consideration
although
towards the end i will ask the committee
moves into public excluded so we can
talk with you directly
without management being present
so look welcome back
committee
appreciate today
i'd like to reconvene our meeting
and start by
returning to receipt of a major late
item
we have three items that we have
received late
and i seek your indulgence to accept
they are the annual report
the letter of representation which we
sign and provide to the auditor
and
also the proposed
audit opinion
which would be signed by derek they're
necessary for us to proceed so i'd like
to move from the chair that we receive
these oh hello gotta get a hand up here
sorry am i a bit quick off the mark yes
through yourself the chair i'd just like
to advise council that the annual report
that um is attached and board books as
their draft annual port
subject to today's events there are some
minor amendments that will need to be
made and updated they will be made
available tomorrow um
for councillors and patricia will give
an update of those
changes when we go through the report
thank you
so well with that i'd like to move that
we
receive these three major late items do
i have a second to please thank you
aaron
that's kerry thank you very much
right um we we have
hello
sorry
can you hear me yes can hear you derek
yeah um maybe just a comment from
outside as well um
with those late adjustments um and
that came through
we have identified
an error in that
so we would need to agree that um that
be corrected as part of
this process
for that adoption to take place
so i didn't quite you say there is
another item
the correct no so
um because of the late adjustment we
went through those adjustments yes prior
to the meeting and we have identified an
error
with the figures that's been proposed
so we can adjust it tomorrow
right okay but it's not going to hold us
up it's not going to hold us up today
here
we just need to recognize in our
resolutions that we have an item to
change okay that's cool
thank you so we have a paper actually
did come with the agenda thank you
patricia well done for the hard yards um
i wonder whether you'd like to
share the key points with us or you or
michael please
thank you
thanks
now
i'll
pretty much take the papers read but i
want to take some make some particular
points
in relation to the end report
so
as we've said there are some late
adjustments and i'll go through those
shortly
the
annual report is different this year
than in prior years because we do
have a difference in opinion between
ourselves and audit new zealand
on the valuation or whether we should
have revaluated infrastructure assets
this year
that is the major item within the annual
report
office's opinion was that while there
were some indicators in the last two
quarters so the march and june quarters
of 21 that prices had increased
significantly we don't consider this was
significant enough there was enough
evidence that we would need to revalue
audit new zealand have taken a diff they
have come to a different conclusion to
that and that is the basis for the
qualification of our infrastructure
assets and our operational land and
building assets
these are all due for a revaluation of
30 june 2022
so they were going to be revalued in the
coming year anyway
so that's the the main point on that one
um there is
and we will go through there's a lot
more detail behind that but i know that
risk and assurance have c have had that
full discussion already
and it's repeated in the paper
now in relation to the late changes from
the version that you've got in board
books
these are in relation to the
consolidation entries so the council
group numbers
um and how we
consolidate
our interests in
associates and joint ventures
very technical um
set of accounting uh rules um and we
needed to correct that error that was
material so we had to bring it through
so that has changed the total assets
figure now
to
1.3 billion dollars
actually hasn't changed it very much
we're talking this was a change of
one and a half million dollars that
we've made through it
but on a on our income statement or a
statement of comprehensive revenue and
expenses which is page 105 of the annual
report
that has changed the bottom line the
total comprehensive revenue and expense
has changed from 12.5 million dollars to
13
or up to 14 million dollars
as we've flowed that through
it has consequences to a number of other
notes as we're throwing changing both
assets and income
and those um
we have been done this afternoon and
passed through audit and
together with the late
the era and these numbers that i've got
in front of me here will be corrected
and made available
when we publish the annual report
for my benefit can you just check to
tell me what is the the slate error
well i would have to actually ask derek
what this late era is because i haven't
been advised of it either hearing it
from derek now is the first time that
i've become aware that there's another
change to these numbers what is the
light here at police there
yes so um with the flow through of
reducing your expenditure
um what you've also noticed is that
consequently the profit in your
associates have reduced
but your
investment in your associates have
increased
we would have expected with a reduction
in the profit usa associate that the
investment in associates will also
decrease
with the same amount
so we need to work through that
with patricia subsequently the meeting
to
determine
what the correcting entry should be
right and so that's going to affect the
balance sheet
yes because
our understanding is that
if your
profit in your associate's reviews your
investment in your associates will
subsequently also reduce
okay thank you so it's it's a
continuation of the same the same error
that you've been chasing i mean i don't
mean that um clinically but you've been
having to chase around today
in terms of the impact of the 1.5
million change okay thank you
anything else you want to raise for us
uh
um
not at this point unless michael you've
got something
that you would like to add
yes through yourself chair just at this
time i'd like to
remind risk and assurance wasn't i
in connection with the
um
difference we had in relation to the
standards we also discussed what the
impact of that was and just um just for
rec noting for record in the public
forum
we did have confirmation in relation to
the impact from fitch that this would
not have an impact in relation to our
credit rating
um and the other side is that this is in
the issue is an increase in our asset
valuation and from perspective of impact
on our bottom line that would improve
our bottom line
so
from
what that means financially it means
we're being very cautious and prudent in
our approach
basically taking a low risk in relation
to the market shifts and what impacts
that has on our accounts
the only thing that we will need to do
is reflect that in the new year in
relation to any changes that may have on
depreciation and future expenses
and reflecting that and increase costs
in our annual plan which we are doing as
well based on the advice that we have
received
thank you
right um thank you patricia thank you
michael for that
derrick is uh before i open up to to
counselors for questions is there
anything that you would like to say at
this stage about either your opinion
that of representation or indeed the
annual accounts
um thank you yes um from our perspective
as patricia already highlighted
uh the old report is qualified this year
due to that
difference with uh
council regarding
um the
fair value compared to the carrying
value we believe there is a material
difference between the possible fair
value of your
property planting equipment compared to
the current carrying value
um so that is the reason why the all
report is qualified for this year also
we did include an emphasis of math
paragraph relating to the three waters
reform
uh where we are making reference to your
own disclosures within your annual
report
regarding that
in terms of the letter of representation
that is a standard representation
[Music]
and there are two uncorrected
misstatements also included
in the representation letter
regarding
um an investment or investment
properties that has been identified at
the end
that has not yet been um or that has
been sold but not yet been account for
property within the accounting records
um
it is below our materiality threshold
but it still
warrants to be included in our
representation later
to acknowledge those those uncorrected
misstatements
also maybe just from
uh
operationally i think i want to thank
management throughout the audit
it's been a tough year a difficult year
we know uh with regard to the extensions
to deadlines
and really want to thank management and
council for their cooperation throughout
the audit process
we really worked well with with everyone
on the team
although we did have our differences
regarding the
matters that we ended up qualifying on
um i think we could
still um we had robust discussions
around that but could and then still
agree to disagree and i don't think our
relationship is in any way affected as a
result of that
thank you jen
thank you derek appreciate that members
of any questions you'd like to ask
darren
thanks chair um look
i think i signaled last week that i'm a
little frustrated that the process
has taken so long and and ended up in a
position where
we get a qualified opinion
um and and it's over professional
interpretation in this instance i was on
council when we last had a qualified
opinion and in that instance we utterly
deserved it
um here you've got a professional
difference of opinion over evaluation
and the timing of which changed
through no fault of our own really
and that is
very frustrating
but i understand it
uh i i guess i'd like to echo derek's
comments and it's nice to hear them um
about the
the cooperation from from our staff and
and
from a councillor perspective want to
acknowledge
the the work that michael and patricia
have done along with the rest of the elt
and providing the information for the
auditors when they've been on site and
chair also to yourself and ross
for the work that you've um done with
them over the this past couple of weeks
and we've had an indication of a
potentially
uh qualified opinion my question for
derek is really is there anything else
that we could have done to expedite the
process because we're
a couple of days away from wanting to
shut down from christmas isn't this is
not when we want to be dealing with this
sort of thing
um
gee i think do you um yeah something i
think this year has been extraordinary
in the sense that
uh from our perspective there has been a
huge auditor shortage
so
um the office of the auditorium
approached parliament to extend
reporting deadlines
um due to our own stock shortages we had
to prioritize
our work in such a way that we can
ensure that
all respective sectors meet their
statutory deadlines
and unfortunately council deadlines are
at the end of that queue
and with the extension being up until
the end of december
all our staff
only allocated to council audits late in
the year
i think
with regards to the issue that emanated
into the qualification
um
i think from our perspective we did pick
up on that quite early and engaged with
management quite early on in the process
although
again granted it was too late for
management to do anything about that at
that point in time
as it's quite an extensive exercise for
management to
go through a full evaluation exercise
um needing to procure service providers
that can do it for them to
go through all council's assets
and so better that in itself is quite a
lengthy and long
exercise to to do that
um so other than that um
we can only hope that that
come next year we're in a better
position from a staffing perspective
to ensure that we can perform the audit
sooner
can i just clarify cheer because
neither of us want to go through this
and and you'll be aware derek that
you know we've had more than our fair
share of publicity with dia so
getting a qualified opinion in your name
right out in parliament doesn't go down
too well
um
can you just confirm for me that
we're that far down the priority list
that it pushed out the time frames it
ends up punishing us is if i
have i got that wrong
yes
again it's council's responsibility to
ensure that
your
carrying value does not um differ
materially from the fair value of assets
and in terms of the accounting standards
you need to
determine that with sufficient
regularity
to ensure that there isn't a material
mismatch between
what you're carrying in your books
compared to what a possible fair value
might be
again through the discussions with
management they believe
the information available at the point
in time
didn't indicate
any material movements
but again you would see from the old
opinion
that there is evidence within the market
that indicated that
they are material movement and
some of those indicators around unit
rates contract prices
and and other
indices
that valuers also use to determine what
the fair value is
we believe that information is available
as at
the reporting date which is the end of
june
um each year
so can you just confirm for me then
derek do we need to review the frequency
with which we go through that
revaluation process
yes
thank you
thank you uh nobby yeah thank you chair
and for your benefit derrick i'm nobby
clark i'm deputy mayor and i have to be
gone in a few minutes time because this
has just dragged on way too long for me
um so i've got some reflections on the
process that's been used as more than
the result itself so i put aside the
qualified or the tagged report
um because i i think it's a an
appropriate gesture and i support what's
the staff position we've got and and for
us to get a qualified report about six
months before we're actually going to do
the revaluation i think just an absolute
waste of everybody's time
but it's more the process for me we had
this
last minute uh exercise last year where
we got reports given to us at the 11th
hour and people really didn't get chance
to go through it i mean i've got two
reports sitting here right now that i
haven't had a chance to read and i guess
we'll accept those today and it's not an
appropriate way for us to do business
it's an important document that we sign
or the mere signs on our behalf with the
chief executive
and we just can't be doing this year on
year on
and so i guess one of the things i want
to signal for audit new zealand is that
it seems to me that the three largest
councils in the country seem to get done
first
followed by some others that might be
reser of concern and then it goes north
to south and so it seems to me that
invercargill is always at the tail end
of this process and while that might be
appropriate on some years it's not fair
to us to be always last in the queue and
to always have our stress running around
doing [ __ ] loads of overtime and
stretching to the max to get this done
in time and it's not good enough um
we had an approach from audit new
zealand earlier on the year about
increased cost and they were quite
significant to our bottom line
and i would have expected that we had
some
improvement in the performance that we
had on the previous year but that's not
been the case
and so it leaves me wondering about why
we have a tag report
or a qualified report whether our
response back to the office of the
auditor general should be
that we're not satisfied with the
auditing we're getting
and that whether we should consider
whether we look for an alternative
third-party auditor which some other
councils do have
um
and so that's an issue for me and i
guess the other issue is the is the
issue that you say you thank us for the
cooperation but there's no recognition
at what cost at our end i mean we've
been sitting around here for hours
waiting for these reports our schedule
today has been an absolute mess if
anybody's watching
doesn't look well for the public when
they focus on it as one of the
colleagues has already said
um so i mean we're a bit lost about
where we go to with us and i guess my
one question i'd leave with you is how
will audit new zealand improve this
performance going forward
and and while staffing is one issue
being at the end of the queue every year
year on year
is not going to resolve our issues we
didn't have it last year and we
certainly haven't got it this year
so i know it sounds a bit negative but i
think
um it just needs to be said thank you
chair thanks navi any response you'd
like to make there
yes thank you gee uh i think from our
perspective it must be recognized as
well that
um the cargo city council does have a
lot of subsidiaries and associates
and all of them feed into the council's
group accounts
all of them have their own reporting
deadlines there and they need to be
concluded before we can
start and finalize the council's
annual report and audit
so there is quite a few audits that lead
up into
the consolidation of the council's
accounts and i think that
also adds to the timing of
the council's own audits
rangi
thank you chair my question derek is
regarding the valuation differences now
on
ian pottinger chair of infrastructure
and looking at the
the uh
that difference
our staff we've got expert staff using
expert advice to
to gain these
valuations obviously
audit new zealand
does use expert staff as well though
they can't do the valuations themselves
now if you use uh
some matrix developed for new zealand
how does that apply to invercargill when
the cost of doing a business in
invercargill is a lot cheaper than doing
business with that throughout the rest
of new zealand that that is a fact
different costs
involving certain infrastructure is
cheaper to do in southland now hopefully
the matrix that audit new zealand used
is not a broad one that just takes a
swiping
medium at new zealand's costs and is
more detail like the one we would use
yes
yes
we do look at contracts across the board
and even contract your own contracts
contracts of
other service providers within the
region
within
your own area within your own town so
it's not only a holistic view across new
zealand we do
make it specific for each
respective council and the area in which
they operate
ross i think um by the way i'm concerned
with a quorum
so
yes i'd like to make certain that we do
proceed reasonably at speed so if we
just have questions that would be great
ross your turn soon
thank you
member of
wrestling accountants
um
sorry derek i'll start again uh ross
jackson independent uh member of risk
and assurance and chartered accountant
uh the first comment i just make is that
earlier in the year parliament passed
legislation to
extend the reporting deadline
in hindsight it would have been
better if it was even longer than this
and
we acknowledge the shortage of audit
staff
in particular and not the work that's
trying to be done to bring them in
across the border but that is going to
be ongoing for some time and
we need to plan better for this coming
year on
all of new zealand's timeliness and
resource and action that now
the other point just going back to the
consistency with other councils that
had their order completed earlier in the
year did not have this issue it's only
because
uh
we have had we have signed off later in
the year
[Music]
and therefore the
looking at the indices
has reflected on the position that we've
had
that you've taken
as a
professional i know we have
debated this and have uh different
professional opinions but
it is difficult to understand
uh what's appropriate to look at the
30th of the september index rather than
30th of june because it wasn't known at
30th of june
and was an adjusting or underlying
event where those circumstances were in
play we're actually in lockdown over
that time so it's pretty hard to
[Music]
look in hindsight
we've got a history of using the burl
and applying it and it's been accepted
previously
so i was questioned why indices are a
fair reflection then should be adopted
um in this
case
um
again the uh public sector uh accounting
standards uh we do have a difference of
opinion on and i guess that's
the position that's been adopted and
we're uh having to reluctantly accept
now
um again i'd
follow on later and look at uh discuss
how we can do better
next year
thank you ross appreciate that
um look i would just like to reflect
that i do think it's important
particularly given the situation we're
faced with which is needing to adopt a
qualified or a modified audit report i
think
i'd like to make it clear to the
committee that um
informally at the very least we will sit
down with derek and chris and debrief
the audit to understand the situation
that's absolutely important in this
situation so we can grab the learnings
out of it do any more questions about
the the opinion
or the letter of representation or the
accounts
now let's
draw your attention to a couple of
things
we're well aware obviously of why we're
being qualified i would just like to
draw your attention if you could take
the draft opinion please
i just want to reflect on what derek is
actually saying here and it's on page
three of the
the draft opinion
which is that he's saying his work is
limited
in other words he can't form an opinion
on the value of our assets
that's the first thing that we should
note is what's being said here
the argument we we have and ross thank
you you've articulated the reasons why
we don't believe this should have
affected the valuation at 30 june
um
but rather would have been disclosed by
way of note recognizing that we would
in
in all cases have to re-value in the
current
financial year
michael in his paper has also indicated
that the economic impact
of this in other words are we worse off
are we less are we less prudent
is not the case
essentially the numbers that we have
reported here other than an impact on
depreciation
is actually
reasonable
the challenge for us will be and and
this is where
we have agreed particularly with derrick
is that actually values are increasing
so when the revaluation does occur
it will have an impact on rates
we will be faced with increased costs
for renewal of assets
so the critical question around here is
the timing of that recognition
derrick's asked us to recognize it in
our
2021 financial statements
we don't believe we needed to
we do recognize that the 2122 will be
affected
even if it wasn't even if it was only
for the fact we do we've got to do a
revaluation but we should expect a
significant adjustment in the nature of
our assets
so that's the first thing i just like to
draw draw attention to here is that
actually
derek is not forming an opinion
on those assets because
he is saying that that his ability to
form a view is
limited okay
[Music]
i think that's the critical thing in
terms of the letter of representation
which while while actually it's being
provided to us by derek thank you it's
actually us writing back to derek and
it's reasonable
for
for uh any auditor to expect us to
represent certain things
i would just like to draw your attention
that while um i think in the preamble
before we met
uh patricia quite rightly said we're
representing quite a number of things
that our systems have operated
effectively through the course of the
year
other than what we might have
acknowledged as being no instances of
fraud or corruption
we are attesting those to him and again
as a committee
council should be looking to us for a
positive recommendation that letter of
representation can be signed so we need
to think of those things in the next few
moments as we actually do it
the other thing that i just want to draw
your attention to
we have a modified opinion
is actually we're also testing and it's
the bottom of page five
of the proposed letter
as to the going concern of invercargill
city council
our obligations are that we are
comfortable that we can meet our bills
as they fall due over the next 12 months
and patricia thank you for your paper
that anticipated the question
and actually there is good there is good
advice there while why we can
assert that
okay so that is the nature of the work
that is sorry the nature of what's been
asked of us
um
uh i i would like um sorry rangi did you
have a question at the stage do you want
to ask no go for it okay thank you so at
this stage
what i'd like to do
mainly because
i do want to have time with derek before
we pass the resolutions i would like to
go to the resolutions because they were
written at a time prior to today and i
need to make certain that they are fully
relevant please okay
so if we go to our agendas
um on page four
of our agenda we have
quite a substantial suite of
recommendations that need to be made
firstly we note um
the risk and assurance committee have
reviewed the drafting report i think is
relevant to to eliminate from this
resolution the ppp darren are you
comfortable with that this week
notes at the time of this report was
prepared the audit field work was
incomplete and sign off was still to be
received well we can
eliminate that now because we have an
effect got signed off from derek
and i think if i read this correctly we
can
we can eliminate this second resolution
correct
radio
we note that the opinion
will have or does have a limited scope
and will not cover the valuation of the
council's infrastructure and operational
assets
limitation of scope is based on the
conclusion that that
based on i've got a few bases here
haven't we based on the increases in
economic indicators available to council
from march to june this year
council should have revalued these
assets that's derek's view
i think we can i think we can get rid of
the subject too
that occurs there because we got rid of
two and three
i don't know what would be subject to
that one we would state
the committee recommends that council
adopts
the 2021 annual report
for invercargill city council
group so it's the group accounts that
we're doing here
um
and i think we can say full stop because
we have the independent auditors report
now
we authorize the general manager it's
michael take it
to make minor changes to the 2021 annual
report prior to its publication and we
need to get rid of if necessary because
it is necessary
okay and i think we've had that
discussion start
today staff
and the auditors have been working hard
to chase around a error in the
consolidation
which essentially is what this needs to
be in here for to permit that to be
finalized um we authorize
uh the mayor and the chief executive to
sign the letter of representation
um and i think again we can say full
stop because it has
been circulated
um
we authorized the general manager to
make changes in history to the summary
annual report we have actually also got
the summary annual report as well that
there will be some consequential changes
to make um
to the summary annual report document
and release of the publication within 20
working days of signing
which is a statutory requirement
and the committee recommends that we
exempt the invercargill community
recreation and sports trust from being a
council controlled organisation
for one july 2021 for a further three
years
noting the decision of council earlier
in 2021 has indicated that this entity
will be wound up
by 30 june
2022 it's a tidying up task chief can we
just go back to seven because i think we
jumped over did i
oh right okay sorry my mistakes darren i
said we authorized the mayor and the
chief well um uh we recommend to council
obviously that the mayor and chief
executive signed the statement of
compliance within the annual report
full stop i don't think we need the
subject to thank you for that so it's a
little representation they need to sign
and statement of compliance thank you
appreciate the the detail nine as i've
said about the trust is just tidying up
a piece of a piece of work there that is
good to have cleared
um i think those are the relevant
information the relevant resolutions
does anybody else have any thoughts on
those resolutions i think they're
reasonably happy with those then michael
clear you're comfortable we can work on
those
right um uh uh i know i've got to catch
up with eric um
so we will look to move these once we've
had a chance to
talk with derek alone without management
to do that i need to move into private i
want the public excluded sorry so from
the chair i'd like to move
uh that we go into public excluded for
the purposes of a free and frank
discussion with the auditor thank you
ross for sitting there
um
all those in favor please say aye right
those against it's carried
we'll try and be as quick as we can
you